you're the flag yes you are a walking
red flag no wonder you're airing
everyone else yes you can't even see us
tiny little our little toothpick things
down here you can't see all that
[Music]
okay I'm ready bro I'm ready as always
I'm ready yes you know guys we go
straight into the question of the week
and the question this week was what's
red wow
I'm saying the alphabet what's one red
flag you wouldn't mind ignore it okay as
per usual
juicy juicy juicy juicy all right what's
one red flag you wouldn't mind ignore in
foreskin
that's what the streets are saying pause
again
okay first of all
yeah pretty good okay first of all uh
why is also gonna red flag this is to be
fair I remember we've had this
conversation before
that's it
I remember this conversation before
because obviously I know that some men
have that like turtlenecking
okay I don't have that okay so like
whenever people talk about foreskin and
was a bit like okay like say it's like
it's not that big a deal but then like
when I've done my research and I've gone
back on my like previous
escapades okay
they'll say that bro to be fair for you
were circumcised okay I'm gonna spoke to
people therefore the first time I forget
the circumcised okay so maybe I don't
maybe I just get triggered for no reason
you know what I mean okay but certain
man yeah obviously your boys spent his
time online I know what's out there in
it unfortunately
you can see probably this much of man's
yeah this this much of man's things at
the top you just get that little
that little Dome at the top yeah yeah so
I'm like when I see that I'm like
but yeah apparently foreskin okay
foreign
s say they make beats
oh why wouldn't you mind ignoring that I
mean uh yeah why would why would you
want to ignore that
when the associated with me I make beats
yeah with his head but
[Laughter]
I do get that because I hate not I don't
necessarily care but I tend to dislike
when I see
um on female socials when I say I'm not
even female so it's just socials in
general when they say oh actor model
something like you don't need to tell me
you're a model or an actor yeah the
streets would have told me yeah do you
know what I mean like Denzel doesn't put
in his body he's an actor we know you're
an actor yeah she doesn't say Dre is a
model we know she's a model yeah just
act or model and we'll we'll do that
we'll find out don't tell me you're an
actor yeah I hate you I hate you I'm a
model yeah
because it just means you're a liar yeah
because bio means wannabe
in it bio basically means wannabe
yeah okay
too much money from an and too much
money from an other blood clot I can't
say
unidentified Source without taking a
break all right let's yeah take a break
too much money from an identity
from an unidentified Source the Lord
promised me abundance
I'm just going to say let's just ignore
that one and move on because because I
just yeah you can't wrap it yeah yeah I
can't wrap my head around it I'm sorry I
couldn't even from and I I still can't
say it from an unidentified Source
I'm spitting oh my God
[Laughter]
see I'm a party hard you know
wow throwback
that she obviously wants to look at her
phone when it lights up but ignores it
hmm
that is a red flag that is a red flag
obviously wants to look at it but she
ignores it how many more
equip him who is it yeah who then what
is it yeah
show me
since you're about to be in love and be
sure
oh
these are meant to be in love
oh what's one red flag you wouldn't mind
ignoring thick saliva oh Jesus family
thick saliva
that's different bro dear friend I
didn't even know they were different
like viscosities for saliva because
because yeah yeah because they're saliva
and then there's phlegm yeah phlegm I
think is what he or she is talking about
and that's grotesque yeah yeah and
that's a waving red flag yeah there's
obviously like there's yeah there's
actually there's three different types
there's saliva which is just like yeah
natural yeah the natural disgusting
whatever yeah then there's spit when
you're it's white and you're thirsty
yeah yeah and then there's phlegm Flem
is which is just gloop yeah it looks
like those aliens that you used to throw
on the wall and then yeah yeah yeah yeah
Flemish from the depth of your soul yeah
yeah
if he's got a big D I can ignore the
three in one shampoo
no three in one [ __ ] no so you've got a
shampoo conditioner probably body wash
shampoo conditioner body wash in one I
probably to be fair
I promise
it was disgusting actual it is how
disgusting and it's it's bad for the
environment sure it's terrible for
everyone that can't run that corrupt
cells
three in one three and one how can you
how can it condition my hair and wash my
armpits it doesn't make sense it just
doesn't make so only literally the only
sense it makes is is just conditioner um
it's just smelly Nice condition oh yeah
yeah yeah it can't be the other two yeah
it just has to be that yeah
yeah they probably just write three in
one well it's probably hand wash yeah
hand wash and they just write three in
one yeah use it and you just play it
everywhere yeah just clean that's sharp
that's the one of the main reasons why I
never use I always bring my like soap on
whatever yeah yeah
when they disappear for an unexposed
amount of time where they still pay your
rent
fair enough raw so he's not even
replying but the rent's still getting
paid right so she's just not even asking
questions you know what my lights are
still on yeah yeah yeah it could be
worse it could be worse it literally
could be worse it could be worse okay
her having an only fans but with only
three Subs
red flag that is a red flag I don't know
what flag color that is bro
that's a checkered flag it's because the
game's over so the race is done it's a
checkered flag it's a checkered flag
it's a checkered flag the race is done
facts bro I could never find that out
that I the thing that I think is a body
a body
and like I'm surprised she even wants to
be with me yeah yeah yeah and she's
doing up only fans you find out you
transfer
some support in it you sign up the
little 999 whatever it is and there's
you and three other man
says following following zero followed
by four
I'd be so disgusted I promise you right
now I'll be so disgusted especially if
she's popping on Instagram she's been
doing it for months the link trees in a
bio for months yeah popping on Instagram
four followers
and she identifies with this career yeah
like where are you getting your money
yeah literally because that's 12 pound
in my opinion yeah yeah you're on
Universal Credit all right you're on
Universal Credit and you're making like
yeah like 20 quid a month on only fans
right continue what's one red flag you
wouldn't mind ignoring
pronouncing the L in salmon salmon yeah
oh God I'm not ignoring that I'm not
ignoring that my ears were put like a
makeover salmon
I'll take the salmon the smoked salmon I
couldn't be on a date with a baddie in
here that no I couldn't you said I'm not
like useless useless and it's just like
I I'll
I'm going to bathroom and wash my face
look at the mirror I'm vain yeah yeah
self-reflection thing I'm vain
Salman I'll be aware we're going to
change what we're going to do yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because where does it go
from yeah because I feel like I'm taking
advantage
I feel like she can't speak the porting
can't speak oh my day Solomon that's
hilarious
he wanted he want him wanting me to be
in
start again and then just say it just
get over with
him wanting me to be the nanny to his
kids just so I can see him more
as a treacherous and she doesn't mind
ignoring that as a mind ignoring that
him want to be the nanny to his kids so
they can see each other more
because he's married
oh we oh we
sticky
one of those tinted screens or cases on
their phones don't worry imma find out
anyway
[Laughter]
don't worry imma find out anyway
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo
no you won't in fact leave me alone no
you won't don't worry calm as [ __ ] don't
worry imma find out anyway
you're the flag yes you are a walking
red flag no wonder you're airing
everyone else you can't even see us tiny
little little toothpick things down here
you can't see all that facts yeah yeah
I want to know how red that flag really
is is it more orange red bright red or
burgundy
man doesn't care
crazy exes because that means he's got
that thing on him
oh no
[Music]
I've got that thang on him oh no
I've never thought about that before raw
raw
laughs
they want all the smoke oh they want all
the smoke
because she was willing to tolerate
anything anything because that pipe is
too good
say less
say less I'm gonna have to just start
acting up to see well yeah just to make
sure
I'm gonna just have to come in in my
boxes and a wife beer just like smashing
stuff and just staring at her
say something staring at her half drunk
Lucas Aid in hand just squeezed
looking like [ __ ] Uncle Ruckus yeah
looking like um was it looking like um
Samuel L in that Meme oh yes yes that's
actually the picture that came to my
head yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
is that from zhango or something yeah
yeah it might be jungle it might be
another one but yeah yeah exactly
between 100 that and then I'll just
leave and slam the door not say anything
and if she's still about it the next day
I know my pipe is yeah you got that
thing yeah I know I got that
dang dang
those jokes
huh she doesn't work but boy does she
give that good loving
um she doesn't work
that's a flag brother
it is
well she got that good loving that Nokia
ringtone oh hell no
hell no that dance
and you know affects me about that it
vibrates twice in between rings so
there's no River
bro yeah bro hell no I'm not ignoring
you oh hell no
when she confidently pulls out a credit
card with another man's name on it
that is why your
and we're just ignoring this we're just
ignoring it
who is she who is who is she for me to
ignore that and who am I for me that's
the question who am I is the question
and what's going on here in in the
social hierarchy where do I think I laid
because I just saw a next man's name and
I just Shrugged I just didn't [ __ ] it so
she's already paying yeah yeah she's
already paying like one strike one and
then his next man's card and I'm
supposed to just sit here and do what I
just found it
just firm it look on the bright side
it could have right so I could be bad
yeah yeah it could be me oh dear I could
be the one whose cards she's spending on
next time
that's why we're ignoring stuff look on
the this is a glass half full moment
yeah this is a learning moment it could
be my car it could be my car that's not
me
I could never
ever
find out my car's been used by my girl
on another date with a man oh bro I
could never just look at like
my statements and just see like
like an odd number to be spent at like
pret a Manger do you know what I mean
and like what did you get 19 pounds I
don't press it spending but it's not 19.
it's not in 19 because you either got
two drinks and a Danish yeah
but like their meal deals like seven so
where are we what's scary yeah you would
have to get multiple drinks or are you
tipping yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean if I
saw 19 pounds of prep yeah you're a
cheat show me the receipt yeah you're a
cheap show me them say or else we're
going down to that store
on a security camera go into that store
and you have to point out what you
wanted
you have to point out what you ordered
19 pounds on prayer yeah that's the
thing if you actually took it down there
and then she was like um um I ordered
this this as soon as I'm seeing two
sandwiches or two beverages I'm walking
out who did you buy this for yeah yeah
because you didn't have a you didn't
have a sandwich for lunch and dinner
yeah for breakfast and lunch yeah yeah
you ain't got this kind of appetite yeah
you don't don't lie to me yeah and you
don't work so it's not even like you
needed to stockpile
well it's not even like you had Regis at
the office you're getting stuff for yeah
who is it work who is he
a guy not using a condom on his first
link like damn I know you are hope this
shit's gonna be good
oh we
yeah all week okay I got a couple more
uh just a reminder what's the one red
flag you wouldn't mind ignore in a bit
of OCD get that hoovering done
[Laughter]
that's hilarious we have get that
hoovering done jokes
cares too much about star signs but
gives me such good head it turns me into
what Aquarius oh my God
even me Goshen it means it's gushing
Oh my days into an aquarius oh that's
true yeah that was that was the um
question of the week guys all right Pang
I hope you liked it all right cool
awesome guys so thank you for coming
back
um happy Monday if you are uh if you're
on top of things if you're on top of
things it's Monday today if you're lazy
it's Tuesday or Wednesday or wherever
whenever you're getting to this
um but yeah guys obviously welcome back
welcome back to shits and gigs welcome
back to the cult and if you really
really really really want to be a true
member of the Court you need to pause
the episode right now right head on over
to patreon.com forward slash shits and
gigs guys so what is patreon what's
going on over there so patreon is the
platform we use to give uncensored
unedited bonus content every single
Thursday we have a massive now massive
Discord server where all the cult babies
come together and discuss cool [ __ ]
Apparently one thing in there was doing
up the splits in a g string the other
day she called it Pole Fitness yeah but
bro I don't know what pole we're talking
about yeah yeah but that's up to the
imagination yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I'm playing but anyway
um so patreon.com it's gonna cost you
three pound a month 10 p a day you need
to run the P to SMG guys and really
really embrace the cult facts
um guys obviously if you are watching us
on YouTube please do us a massive favor
and subscribe to the channel if you are
listening on any podcast app please give
us a review as always guys five stars is
preferable but whatever you need to say
say it with your chest and we'll be done
with it okay cool back to the episode I
need to introduce you to my
co-founder my best offender
Fire Lord flakes who's going to educate
us hit us with some knowledge let us
know what's going on the world today
let's go you probably know this already
uh Mr Beast is now is now the most
subscribed YouTube content creator after
overtaking PM PewDiePie
PewDiePie
PewDiePie PewDiePie yeah I did know this
yeah I thought so
um Jimmy Donaldson better known as Mr
Beast has officially become the number
one YouTube influencer with 111 million
subscribers and Counting after reaching
his longtime goal of acquiring 100
million 100 million subscribers in July
Mr Beast continued growing his fandom
according to Forbes the 24 year old
earns are earned around 20 54 sorry
million dollars in 2021 which his net
worth is currently around 25 million
dollars he reportedly makes around 5
million dollars a month making you
making him YouTube's highest paid
content creator
yeah he makes racks bro he makes racks
and spends right he does he does because
I I think this past week I've been
binging quite a few of his videos while
I've been like packing and organizing my
stuff and whatever and because I
subscribe to him as well and I've only
seen the ones I've seen in the past are
like the Charlie the Charlie and
Chocolate Factory one the um squid games
one and I think I've seen another one as
well but yeah she's randomly binging
them I was thinking see I was randomly
thinking like yo you make racks but you
spend on these videos you [ __ ] spend
on these videos I would love to
obviously I think you mentioned it
before was it Mr BC was saying that how
he he always asks people in any circle
like oh what's the best thing for
YouTube what's the best thing for that I
think was it you
elaborate what do you mean um because
well the question I wanted to ask is
that I wonder how
he how he starts I'm not seeing his I
don't know what his first video is okay
so I wonder how he started and if he
went down if he went down the route of
what he's doing now I.E
um spending money to like create and uh
create a video for like audience members
or people that he brings in or whatever
so I don't know how we even I broke into
that broke into this space because so
all of these videos are so expensive
yeah so he used to do he's always done
like challenge based videos okay and a
lot of them would be with himself okay
um and like he's done like others he's
done like stuff where like I'm he's done
videos where he's
um like I think he did one way count it
to ten thousand or maybe a hundred
thousand really just sat there and
counted and that was like I think that
video blew up oh wow and um he's done
ones where he's like I think he said
like Logan Paul like a a [ __ ] ton of
times just said there was Logan Paul
Logan Paul Logan Paul Logan Paul like
like I don't even know like a hundred
thousand times or something ridiculous
like that he's always done like weird
challenging type stuff and then he
slowly transitioned because he does a
lot of like philanthropy stuff he's
passionate about like giving yeah um so
then I guess as he started making money
he's like slowly started to include that
and I think when it really started was
when he started getting sponsorships
okay so there were like I think there
was times where they've been like oh I
think maybe the first time I might be
wrong I'm pretty sure the first time he
gave away like a decent amount of money
was a sponsor came to him and were like
oh we'll give you five grand to do this
video and he said give me 10 grand and
I'll just give the money away and I
promise you the video will do better
than if you just gave me five grand to
yeah for me to have and lo and behold
they gave him the money he gave the
money to to the contestants and stuff
like that
um and ever since then it's been like
give money for this give money for that
and then he's always had like a very
game show challenge style type of
content
um that people seem to obviously love
and uh yeah man that's why we got into
like the the given money style things
and a lot of it was always
a sponsor will come like we'll pay you
half a million for this video and then
all of a sudden that video he'll be
giving away half a million I know a lot
he said he's mentioned a lot of times
that that will he gets tripped up in
that because as we know now a lot time
Brands take a long time to pay you yeah
yeah so there's been times we've had to
take out massive loans okay uh because
yeah he'll pay obviously he has to pay
when he gives it to people yeah he just
gives it them on the spot on the spot
yeah and then he's got like employees to
pay and he's got like to live and all
this stuff so like there's been times to
take out massive loans oh sure and then
obviously the responsible pain or pay
off his loan and stuff like that but
like I think he he said like now I'm
pretty sure he's got like enough money
in his bank that he never has to do that
so he can give away a million did you
see the video he did the other day where
he gave chunks his debit card yeah well
so I saw what everyone had to touch the
jet yeah so I saw that video but I
didn't see the video chunks there of him
spending oh I saw it yeah I didn't see
that video yeah yeah I saw the video of
everyone touching the Jet and blah blah
blah yeah I saw that video they spent
money on it I did that's what 10 bugs or
something like 100 bags
bro they just went and they just went
Harrods they didn't go anywhere else
they were spending money in there to be
fair if if Mr Beast offered me that
whilst I was touching a jet for like God
knows somebody else I would do exactly
the same oh trunks wasn't about it he
was not about it in that video oh no he
was done immediately yeah he looked
knackered and I was I remember because
of the timing I was thinking I wonder if
this was the day after we saw him
um
yeah yeah nothing he looked shattered
yeah he was doing stuff last night
um but yeah man like I I I'll I can talk
about Mr Beast for hours he's killing it
I'm surprised it's taking him this long
to get in front of PewDiePie but like um
PewDiePie's just been like
PewDiePie's like the go of it
he does all sorts but he's very
minimalist style okay he's always like
him headphones like he doesn't do these
like grandiose okay videos it's just him
in his room headphones on just even
narrating to stuff reacting to stuff
gaming stuff whatever he just does that
kind of content but he's just been doing
YouTube for
sorry
he's been doing YouTube Forever fair
enough
forever so yeah man um
like yeah literally good on him
um he's he's doing he's doing the damn
thing for sure seems like it mum like
all these videos are ugly too clean I
watch quite a few of them quite a few of
them the other day yeah man he knows
what he's doing he does um right so one
thing I need to talk about um
I'm way late now I'm over a week late
but we're gonna talk about it so
I'm sure everyone knows my boy Izzy lost
oh yeah bro so I watched the highlights
so I'm involved this time right involved
this time so
yeah
yeah
um watch highlights of all three
yeah they were good right they were good
right the Poirier did I not tell you you
did I not tell you that was gonna be a
war round one I've never seen body blows
like him bro they were gushing with
blood yeah so we'll get away yeah
um
oh let's talk about that okay so UFC 281
was a week and a bit ago now
um and yeah so the main the main card
was
um or the fight of the night was style
Bender Israel at the Sonia versus uh
Alex Pera
and I I can't remember if I spoke about
it on a patreon episode where I spoke on
a YouTube episode but
um the basic consensus was is that
um style Bender it was the UFC
middleweight world champion right and
he's been there for a while and there's
been a lot of people that have been
trying to take the crown off him and no
one's managed to do it uh and it was it
wasn't looking like he smashed everyone
in the division so there was it was
looking like it was never going to
happen so his arch nemesis from his
kickboxing days Alex Pereira
um had also transitioned into MMA and
was climbing through the ranks fast so
the UFC gave him a quick
pass go collect 200 pounds
little quick route to the top and gave
him a title fight because they knew he
would be trouble yeah for style bender
and lo and behold he was troubled for
him he was um five rounds of death
literally five rounds of war and both of
the guys were a little bit like
hesitant
um and one thing I told you as well so
um obviously style Bender rarely uses
his Jujitsu or his grappling okay
um and I think it was in the second
round maybe or the third or maybe even
the first Alex took him down
um and then you could tell someone's
like say less if you want to do floor
work yeah yeah you want to do a floor
work yeah yeah say less so then there
was another one we tried to take him
down reversed it took Alex down Alex
gave him his back he literally took his
back I was just wading into his face so
you could tell Alex is not about it on
the ground okay it's not about it on the
ground
um but
so there's a little bit of controversy
which has kind of been squashed now but
basically there is a narrative that
people are saying that the fight got
stopped too early
I kind of saw that towards the end yeah
so
um
star bundles win in the fight up until
the last round he was winning the fight
so in order for Alex to win this fight
and become Champion he needed to knock
salvander out and lo and behold in the
fifth round he rocked his jaw got him
against the defense rocked his jaw and
Izzy was all over the place but he was
conscious enough to keep bobbing and
weaving he wasn't just laying there
getting smashed but he was getting
smashed up he was and the the ref
stopped him when he wasn't unconscious
he wasn't flawed he wasn't but his eyes
were spinning that was clear as day yeah
yeah his eyes were spinning but in in is
his defense
he was down but he was still moving his
arms were still up he wasn't like out
here and his argument was is that same
referee
was the referee of a fight that he had I
think this was the fight he got the belt
actually okay uh a bit against Kelvin
Gastelum okay and that was a war
elsewhere
that was a walk okay
both of them got knocked down in that
fight elsewhere and gasoline got knocked
down like five or six times he got
rocked and somehow managed to keep
getting up and that same ref and then
when it's basically um Starbucks
argument was like this is the same ref
that let homeboy get put on his ass like
five times because this is a title fight
yeah yeah and you need to go out on your
Shield yeah okay but the same ref is
telling me that this fight's over when
I'm still here with my arms up and I'm
just I'm bopping and he was like this is
done done but yeah and then like so I
can sympathize with style Bender
starbender's not saying if something is
not necessarily saying I was gonna make
it but he was basically like let me find
out if I was gonna make it because I'm
not on the floor yeah I'm not like arms
down don't know what's going on my arms
are up I'm moving my head I'm still here
I'm about I'm still here you don't touch
me up don't look at my eyeballs yeah
yeah yeah they'll tell you lies yeah
they'll tell you they'll tell you I'm
unconscious but look at my posture and
everything like that and you are the
kind of ref that we looked for in that
last fight where you were just letting
homeboy carry on carry on after I put
him on his ass spare times but
that was it
that I think they're gonna have a
rematch
I saw Ray um he went on um the flagrant
pod afterwards he did go on the
playground I haven't listened to it yet
but yeah I watched it um actually
we'll get back to that specific topic
the tea he wore
it was like you know obviously well not
you know obviously you know about the
people might not know who loves um anime
narrative blah blah he wore the dirtiest
Naruto top I swear it was like I think
it was um it said hidden but I couldn't
see where it said at the bottom but it
was Naruto holding
um the NBA trophy like Jordan did when
he won the treble or you know I mean
yeah yeah it was that and it looked buff
oh the most annoying thing about it I
went through the comments on YouTube and
I went through the comments on his
Instagram because he posted a pic of him
wearing that tea as well
everyone was talking about oh you're a
true Jen blah because he's he's he
doesn't what um wallowing is like
failure yeah yeah he's very super open
about it yeah yeah and everyone said oh
you're the champ you're still the champ
blah blah coming through no one was
focusing on the shirt where's the shirt
from you know what I mean no more
focused yeah it made me think about do
you know what's great it made me think
about you know when you see a baddie in
a group picture right I think where's
that at where is it where is it where is
the [ __ ] at then you find that
one person that has all her at his girl
in the green dress
you're right think like me and there
needs to be more people like you in this
world because this is all we care about
that's all I cared about was that sure
where did you get that shirt from and
nobody was focused
bro that would piss me anyway yeah sorry
um so we're on the playground he went on
a flagrant party he was talking about
how in this either the first or second
round he kicked him in like the back of
his um ankle here he said he's like
perineal perineals yeah said from then
his footwork wasn't what he used to be
yeah he normally is yeah
um so that's obviously not an excuse to
reason why he he thinks he lost but he
said it was a factor but he was going on
obviously you could um when you listen
to it you'll see how so humble he was
about like he just he not like he didn't
care but he's like he's had many other
disappointments or greater
disappointments in his life they were
just so refreshing to see that yeah I've
seen um I've seen a few little like bits
here and there of him just like
commentating and just saying look man is
what it is yeah
um like he still says about the I still
think they should have let it go on a
little bit longer yeah but he's not
saying
um
yeah he's saying I should have let it go
on a little bit longer in my opinion but
at the end of the day I lost his losses
I lost and we'll have to chalk it up to
the next one but yeah he's like bro this
is it this is this is the game we play
yeah yeah and you have to lose and I saw
um he got sent something from Muhammad
Ali's team oh okay the other day he got
sent like uh this like comparison pick
thing of like Ali like with a afro
picking his hair okay a style Bender
with afro picking his hair okay and Ali
doing something else is that but they're
doing the same thing kind of thing and
it basically said just like
um the losses are the most important
thing that's cool yeah this is like
exactly the losses are everything and
just like a sick Muhammad Ali quote
um and I was like that's gang that's
very very cool and like I'm excited for
them to fight again but
here's the thing right
Alex Pereira is like
a horrible matchup for starbender okay a
horrible matchup and I think and in that
fight as well Alex was very reserved
they were both reserved but Alex was
also very reserved because this is the
first time he's had to do five rounds
Alex Alex is the first time he's
Stoppers were doing five rounds for time
now but only the Champions do five
rounds okay everyone else does three
only the championship fights you do five
rounds so this is his first time at five
rounds so it would have been very normal
for his coaches to be like hold back
yeah because this guy's gonna want to
scrap you if you fall into that you're
gonna be knackered and he's been here
before he stayed in this in this car you
don't know what's like up here so just
hold back so now he knows what five
rounds is like there's nothing to say
that like next time he might just come
out guns blaze it and it could be even
worse for style Bender so I'm interested
to see what they do
um I'm interested to see what he changes
I would love for style Bender to just be
like I'm gonna wrestle the tits off of
him because we I had him up on the floor
and he couldn't do anything so I'm just
gonna go for takedown for takedown for
takedown but it's always a case of like
in the moment people will always Resort
back to their basic training of course
and his basic training is kickboxing and
he's always going to go back in the in
the tough moments he ain't gonna shoot
for a double Leg Takedown he's going to
want to go for his his training and go
for that attitude in the temple bro on
top of that he's
um I'm pretty sure as far as
middleweight goes he's the tallest he's
taller than starbender oh Alex is taller
than star
Bender's like six four no yeah he's tall
bro Alex is taller than him oh [ __ ]
um and Alex is like naturally way bigger
than him he's a natural light
heavyweight I don't even know what he's
doing him he's a natural light
heavyweight and I wouldn't be surprised
if he starts going up and challenging
for the light heavyweight titles
um and it's so annoying as well I don't
see him being trapped if if they have
the rematch and starbender loses again
it's going to be a massive
disappointment because all that's going
to happen
is so
he can't mess with anyone on the ground
Alex can't okay he can't mess with
anyone on on the ground okay and the top
five
um in the middleweight division are
disgraceful wrestlers okay
disgraceful wrestlers okay so you can
see now that they've seen that he's
fought style Bender because as long as
darbin is King he's beat every single
one of these man and they've not come
close to beating him okay now they've
seen
Alex is so dog [ __ ] on the floor all of
them and everything together I can't
[ __ ] wait to fight this challenge I
can't wait to fight this bro because I'm
taking a bow it's a rap yeah he can't he
gonna be this do nothing this kickboxing
ain't gonna be [ __ ] he's not gonna be
able to do nothing and then the whole
cycle is going to change and it's it's
annoying that you can just play the
matchups like that it's just like I can
be the champion champion you bring me
one brayer who is better at me than what
I do but it's way worse at the stuff
that I don't do and the stuff that I
don't do is what's kept me Champion me
being okay at wrestling has been the
sole reason why I've been championed all
this time and the fact that he's [ __ ]
wrestling but it's just better at
kickboxing
every single person I've beat is gonna
come up and smack him yeah and then I'm
gonna have to start here and then work
my way up again to take the belt off the
breath that I've already beat yeah time
ago easily he said in the I'm sorry to
keep going about the flag of he said on
on that um pod that even if that does
occur I.E
um Pereira fights someone else or
someone challenges prayer first before
he does because he said he said he might
uh he might do surgery or something
happen to his knee or whatever yeah so
he said he might do that so if he's like
recovering and stuff and Pereira fight
someone else in the interim and Pereira
loses
um style better said he still wants to
fight Pereira that's what he said I
believe what he said I feel like at the
time you would say that I feel like at
the time you're heated and all this
stuff and you realize I was winning bro
I was winning I was winning yeah yeah
um but it's like
I wouldn't recommend it I just wouldn't
recommend it because
starbenders everything that style
Benders advantages have been he negates
all of them
um he's taller than him he's his reach
has been a massive factor in his like
Championship okay he's like his reaching
his his height have been like massive
factors in terms of why he's such a good
yeah middleweight and stuff like that
and Alex is bigger and better like he's
bigger than him he's taller than him his
reach is longer than him
um he's stronger than him
this reminds me of remember that Jaden
Jaden Smith and Justin Bieber song I
can't remember what the song is called
but we say he's bigger than me taller
than me he's stronger than me
as he was saying on my head I can't
remember
he's a physical specimen yeah yeah he's
bigger than he was stronger than you and
he is potentially a better kickboxer
than you so it's just not worth it okay
it's just not worth it okay play to be
the champion but I know starbender is
more than a UFC fighter he's a martial
arts purist and he only cares about
being the best okay which is what I have
to rate him he's not going to play the
safe thing okay he only cares about
being the best best whoever beats him he
needs to prove to everyone that he will
be him before he continues his reign as
Champion he has to and like
I'm happy he has that mentality but also
as a fan of him you just want what's
best for him yeah and what's best for
him is to steer clear of this prayer let
him lose to another breath and then just
[ __ ] off whoever took his crown take
your crown back and then just not let's
not entertain this anymore but hey ho um
and then on top of that the Poirier
Michael Chandler fight yeah that I was
surprised it was crazy because
um obviously I didn't watch it live I
watched three separate uh YouTube
highlight videos yeah you have that one
and I can't remember the the two ladies
I thought as well prior as well
Whaley yeah I saw that but what I
watched the two ladies fight then um
Chandler fight and then the Pereira
fight so when I was watching the trailer
fight and probably I was thinking how is
this not the main the main problem it's
gonna be a war
wow as soon as I remember as soon as I
looked at my friends I didn't even know
these men were fighting yeah yeah she
doesn't look to my phone I saw that
match up I was like Jesus Christ fam it
was blow off the blow off the blower bro
Jesus Christ both like five nine five
ten stock short Kings
stock oh they were fighting James yeah
yeah bro wow the one thing I will say
um that that's not enough people giving
credit for is Michael po Dustin
poirier's
calmness and focus in those incredibly
heated situations is insane it's insane
because Michael China was throwing
everything in here everything yeah
everything at him yeah and he would
always stay focused and he'll get them
straight shot Michael's throw in
everything and he'll just be there bang
bang and just still bang straight bang
and he just focused he never loses his
temper never loses his call bro and
Michael China can wrestle he can wrestle
and then Dustin caught him in a rear
naked choke to finish the fight say less
say less
bro yeah but did you see
um
this is one thing I would have tapped up
promise you I wouldn't have won this
fight if I was just in Fourier because
when I was on my back and homeboy's nose
was spilling in my face James
he was breathing it all in his face
dirty little bastard yeah he was
breathing all this blood in his face and
I would have been like yo yo yo yo yo
take your nickel you win because this
can't run I didn't sign up for this yeah
yeah I'm tasting hemoglobin that's not
mine and that's disgusting I'm tasting
iron yes it's just pure iron it's wrong
yeah it's wrong get the [ __ ] off me yeah
I would have screamed it yeah get off me
I would have screamed it
promise you now people would lose all
respect for me as a fighter because when
I'm doing the after commentary example
what happened I'm like you saw myself
there was blood yeah from his nose into
my mouth there was clumps of his brain
falling out into my face like of course
sometimes yeah do I look like Jeffrey
Dahmer to you bro I'm not dealing with
that I'm not eating I just want to fight
that's all I'm here for yeah I want to
fight no one said anything about pouring
blood into my mouth like on some ritual
thing yeah yeah Tap Out facts we'll run
it back yeah knock me down as far in the
rank is as you need to knock me but we
can run it but we'll run it back next
time because I'm not dealing with that
I'm not dealing with that I want kids
but bro it was wild yeah that was wild
yeah that was that was just graceful
stuff but yeah that whole card was a
scrap okay guys you already know what it
is it is time to pay the bills we have
lots of Lights to keep on and the best
way to do it is to inform you guys about
the ground breaking boys and girls over
at manscaped okay guys so if you think
your holiday spread is good it's time to
give thanks to the manscape performance
package 4.0 or as I like to call it the
perfect package for your package okay
the perfect package for your package
thanks all right so inside you're gonna
find that lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer the
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner what else and performance
boxer brief come on
okay guys so right if you want to get
involved like us okay so this is the
thing people message me all the time I'm
like oh you see that my skating you
actually use it like do you actually use
it bro I stay using it stay I stay using
it the other day I thought my charger
was broken and I nearly had a panic
attack I stay using also it wasn't
broken
because it's from landscape yeah come on
come on man it's top of the line so guys
uh if you want to get involved if you
want to jump on the bandwagon with us
all you need to do is head on over to
manscape.com and use the code s n g
November golf
to get yourself 20 off and free shipping
World Wide thank you for listening let's
get back to the episode dang scrap
really really really good and also I
didn't because obviously we spoke about
it whether it was a patreon or YouTube I
can't remember and you said it was that
Sunday whatever but like 3 A.M I thought
it was
Monday at 3am my brain full Monday
through so I was waiting but because
when I woke up on Sunday thinking oh if
the thing's tonight I'll see you in bed
yeah yeah I'm thinking how are these not
predicting stuff already yeah I've seen
best I saw on YouTube I saw on Twitter
so I was thinking [ __ ] I missed I'll
take bro I respect as well because I
actually forgot about it I knew I was
gonna watch the highlights the next day
or the match the next day and um
you know the Mourinho meme with the
heads just like yeah yeah that was me
because I naturally opened uh I
literally fam I opened my Instagram yeah
and the first thing on there was House
of highlights with Alex Pereira busting
my boy's chin and they said and Lou yeah
and I was like Marina [ __ ]
the first thing you wake up to first
thing [ __ ] this yeah I was like nah bro
not my boy because I knew he gave it his
all yeah Rags Rags rags and I was so I
was even more good at him when I
actually watched the fight and thought
this guy's winning this guy's winning he
was doing bits in the first four he was
doing bits in the first one he would
have been so gassed to win that fight
for her I can imagine he felt like he's
your boy yeah just knowing how gassy
would have been to win that it's crazy
like you say that you feel like he's
your boy because in the um in the
interview you did with fragrant pod
um he said a lot of people are asking
him uh or saying to him oh sorry about
all how did you feel and blah blah I'm
cool I've had a bag of disappointments
in my life trust me this is the least of
my life yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then
Schultz was like
um I feel like the reason why people oh
no and then um Israel was like uh maybe
because if they were in my shoes they're
probably thinking about how they would
feel if they were in my shoes and they
start to get a bit defensive saying that
oh well they wouldn't even be in my
shoes anyway blah blah yeah but then um
stopped and be like I feel like the
reason why people were are asking you
how you feel and probably depending on
you or whatever is because you're a
consistency in their life literally
every time they see your name in a card
they know you're going to show up my
life could be a wreck but I know when I
see when I watch UFC next Sunday and
you're you're fighting I know you're
gonna win and I you're talking about me
I rely on them you're talking about me
yeah so that's I was like wow I rely on
these things which is the first this is
the first UFC fight I've ever won where
I go I was nervous yeah yeah I was
nervous bro because I was like there's a
very very very good chance he'll lose
this hey very good and I just can't see
it yeah because he is my rock yeah these
are my rock yeah yeah it's crazy this
spread fictionally wrote someone's name
in a Death Note that's crazy that's
crazy
he's the guy bro and it's like when you
watch it and you're like oh no he might
lose this and then you think you watch
the fight he's like now he's winning
he's actually winning he's gonna [ __ ]
win he's gonna [ __ ] win he's actually
gonna win he's Unstoppable bro last
round homeboy comes out and just says
yeah yeah
I'm King now yeah I'm King now Rock till
mine I need it speak
and then you'd have to be like and then
yeah literally not even a case of
literally exactly Andrew Schultz can be
very intellectual sometimes and that is
a spot on it's not even I don't feel bad
for him because I think that's how I
would feel in his shoes at all I feel
bad because literally I rely on him to
win fights to make me feel good yeah
because I my life is so inconsistent
that he's the only company he's a
constant and like he's come against so
many different people all of which
people are I think this might be it I
think this might be it I think this
might be it and he smacks them up every
single time and he not only does he
smack him up he makes them look stupid
bro like [ __ ] Liverpool last season
everyone was betting against them but if
they won every almost every game yeah in
most seasons they're winning everything
he's the constant and then when when you
when you see people like you you heard
me bro I was getting angry at the
flipping at Dana for thinking for giving
him the shortcut to the title fighter
yeah you did that was weeks ago yeah you
man or a weapon formed against it yeah
yeah Ops
that's it it's me stopping against you
man you man are literally off so what
are you doing bro what are you doing my
guy this is my guy what are you trying
to do this on purpose bro what are you
doing bro
um so yeah fam that yeah but anyway
it happens it is what it is moving on
um but I know I've stayed as far away
from this topic as humanly possible but
I know by Cristiano Ronaldo your boy
Ronaldo was running his gums do you know
the smart thing about
um Piers Morgan I don't really
necessarily have any um
opinions on the guy himself yeah um but
obviously everyone has seen the clips
that he put out for this have you seen
the clips he put out for the for this
interview at all oh I've seen little
bits and Bobs yeah
so I can't remember I can't remember
what the clips were but it was one of
those ones where he said the the
interview is going to be two-parter oh
okay so he played it smart oh he played
it so smart because everything in
episode one which I watched yesterday at
yours was so light oh okay so everything
all the clips we've seen that that one
social was like on Monday or whatever
are clips from episode two
you know what I mean so everything so it
started off with him talking about
um his return to United
um I'm sure most people know he had a uh
he had a death in his family one of his
um one of his babies was stillborn I
believe I said we'll talk about things
like that talking about um Georgina his
misses talking about
um some of his ex-collies I.E Wayne
Rooney and uh Neville Gary Neville yeah
not really showing him the support and
love that he thought they would give him
uh for coming back
yeah
the stuff happening on and off the pitch
and it's like he said like these are my
boys like I trained with them I played
with them blah blah blah and it's like
why
why would they treat me like this kind
of thing so it's one of those ones where
because I've not seen um episode two I
can't really go deep into the matter but
it's also one of those ones where you
see you see you do see Ronaldo in a
different light because
um I've never seen a Ronaldo interview
before yeah most well unless you're like
a die-hard Die Hard Die Hard you would
have probably seen something like on in
different um different medium stuff I've
never seen a Ronaldo interview ever
um and it's one of those ones where you
see like he's
He commands respect because he gives
respect and
he will talk to you honestly and
truthfully about how he's feeling
because he's a human being not
necessarily because it's an egotistical
thing yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah granted he is the most famous
person in the world yeah he's one of the
richest people in the world yeah granted
he's one of
arguably the best player in the world
yeah I mean these are three major
pillars to have but he's also still a
very very humble person don't get me
wrong the things that
um have come out in well by the time
this is out the second episode of the
app I've not seen it yet but the things
that have come out um the clips that
have were shown for the second episode
it's like you can't
you can't say these things whilst you're
still at the club you know what I mean
bro like when we spoke a few weeks ago
when I said to you we were talking in
Tottenham two nil and we had one of the
best games we've played not in terms of
just the scoreline but the stats yeah
the atmosphere it was in Old Trafford
yeah and I like the 87 minute he walked
out of the title he walked down the
tunnel went to the changing room yeah
caught in his car and left he left mad
he left OT before the players got back
to the changing room do you know what I
mean so it's like I understand you say
all these things about
um well he doesn't say he's not
egotistical but the way he carries
himself sometimes you may believe he's
not egotistical but also like that is
not acceptable yeah it's not respect
that's not respect yeah if we're going
to talk respect yeah yeah you are yeah
yeah that's not respectable at all and
it's not acceptable in the whip bro
didn't even wait in the changes bro he
got his stuff and dips yeah but on the
back side of that the reason why he said
he did that was because I think the week
before or a couple weeks before that's
when we played City and we got tucked in
six free we play Tottenham I think that
same week or the week after
we beat him too you know but
um Ralph not Ralph right next [ __ ]
out Erikson Hogan wanted to only put him
on
um at like the 85th minute Ronaldo and
it's like you say he said that
um when I say he said I mean Ronaldo
said
um Eric Van Hogan said he didn't put him
on the pitch for the city game out of
respect six three whatever
let me not disrespecting my pointer like
it's what what for yeah yeah yeah but
then the same
um Ericson Hoggers putting him on where
two nil up and there's 85 minutes are
you putting on Ronaldo like what you
should have put me on a half time of
starting me do you know what I mean so I
could understand
that Dynamic but
there are certain things that just
shouldn't be done and obviously the main
I feel like the main catalyst for him
doing this interview was
um
about his um his daughter passing away
and he said he went to the United ball
and then this and the um whoever like
runs it and stuff and obviously Eric as
well saying um oh X Y and Z I need some
time off blah blah blah
um and they said he didn't believe him
but what they did just the way
not word for word they said they didn't
believe him but it's it was it's
basically what he said do you know what
I mean yeah no no no no no not the fact
that she passed away because we all know
she passed away not that but the way
they handled this situation because he
wanted time off he didn't pre he didn't
train preseason with us I was thinking
why he's not training preseason but then
I was thinking does he need to trade
reasons
we had new players and we had a new uh
he had a new coach
he should have trained you know yeah
yeah yeah we were just thinking he's
being stubborn yeah yeah you know what I
mean yeah yeah
um or being egotistical yeah I mean yeah
and it's one of those ones where if I
was in his shoes and I went to the board
of directors of Manuel any football club
or any team or whatever and I said yo
I'm having a terrible crisis in my
family life right now I'm in need some
time and the response he gets is
somewhat similar to like a shrug on the
shoulders I don't believe you kind of
thing
that's disrespectful so that's the re I
feel like that was the Catalyst for him
to do this because it involved it wasn't
just about him it was about obviously
yeah like I always like to think like
you need to judge until they prove you
wrong yeah you should always judge
people based on their merits exactly so
like if I like I'm Cristiano Ronaldo bro
the name alone yeah the lame alone is
just like if I tell you I can't train
yeah and I can't be here you should
think Hmm one of the greatest players of
all time says and one of the most
passionate people I've ever met says he
needs to go bro I'm not even asking any
questions go because he's the first one
to turn up a training he's the last one
to leave all the time yeah yeah so you
can tell it's not he's not gassing yeah
right it's not gas Rags listen to what I
have to say you know what I mean so I
feel but I think it was because
um he did that um that tunnel thing
at Tottenham and he did something else I
can't remember what he did
um that obviously started him up in the
media again so after those after those
two things and then for him to try and
say I need some time off whatever
because um he had family issues and
stuff and he said he didn't believe him
I feel like that was the last straw for
him yeah so I can
I can understand the reasonings behind
again I've not seen the second episode
or the second part of the um episode but
I can understand the reasons behind his
frustration and wanting to speak his
truth but I think
personally he should have done it he
should have left United and then done
the interview
because it's done now oh he can never
come back but he's also done it at a
really good time because we have this um
mid-break because of the World Cup dust
by the way you can't [ __ ] wait
talk about it in a second yeah um
so yeah he's kind of done it in a time
where he knows after this interview he
doesn't need to speak to United again
because for a fact they're going to let
me go or I'm going to leave he's been
fighting a million pounds but that's all
I think to him yeah yeah
um but then he can focus solely on
Portugal and the World Cup and then
whatever he does after that in December
also sorry to cut you off if I know I'm
getting booted I'm not giving you a
million pounds even if it is nothing to
me I don't care okay he will go to
school I didn't find him I don't care
I want to keep playing for you then yeah
I'll give you the million but if I know
I'm gonna blame for you I'll do what I
want say less
um because in Portugal
the president of Portugal will do
something about it yeah
because he needs me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
in the airport is named after me I've
got the airport I've got a museum in
there and just what my world cup shirt
sales are going to do for our economy
alone you're gonna need me in there yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I'm telling you now
you're not getting a million from me
because I'll say what I want to who I
want when I want because I know I'm not
playing for you anymore I don't need you
man anymore yes take me to court yeah
because I promise you
Don is gonna come in on a plane and saw
some sign out here because I'll bet him
like these men are saying I can't play
football
period for you or for anyone but they I
heard they said especially for you yeah
they said the last
the judge said backstage the last place
he's paying his Portugal I heard him say
it
all these Mana Ops please do something
do something like [ __ ] say less he's not
a jet I'll be there in 10. I'll be there
in 10 that night yeah yeah my boy nah
never never never but yeah I'm I'm
looking forward to watching um the
second half of the episode or the second
half to the interview
um it should be very eye-opening
considering
the whole controversy about him but
Peterson Morgan asks frustrating
questions he does he does but he also
knows what he's doing he knows what he's
doing but yeah he's asked really like
antagonizing questions like real leading
like uh one of the few Clips I did see
was him about like with the when um
Ronaldo's talking about like Rooney and
Neville yes and then and he's talking
he's talking on like a heartfelt thing
yes these are my boys we trained
together and he's like do you also think
they're jealous because you're still
playing and they're not playing and it's
like that's such an irrelevant question
and he answered and he was like yeah
maybe I just say no just say no they had
a flourishing career yeah I'm sure
they're fine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're doing just fine I forgot
about that bit yeah I thought I was like
you're a waste man he does do that he
his views in it yeah he only cares about
the views Pearson knows what he's doing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
um that leads me on to a show
recommendation I want to talk to you
about say less it is called FIFA
uncovered okay wow oh what have you seen
it wow yeah so FIFA company is just it's
basically about how they started FIFA I
think it started like 1904 or 1917
something like that
and
um they they wanted to plan how they can
do like obviously International games
and this that and the other and get the
whole world to know about football and
stuff
um so basically it's about Seb platters
Seb blatter's life he's the ex FIFA
president uh he got sacked a few years
ago
but
so it started off with the English
better he was the president at the time
of like back a day I can't remember what
it was and then it was a Brazilian
brother called Joy I can't really
surname joao something
um and Seb was his understudy at the
time
so at that time I think they were
gearing up to the 1974 or 1978 World Cup
which was in Argentina at the time and
in Argentina at the time they were
living in a um
what's the word I'm looking for uh
dictatorship so it wasn't the best place
to do anything okay and yeah the
president at the time was on stuff it
was also [ __ ] also if you say at the
time one more time I'm leaving the
podcast
at the time
um
[ __ ] sake
um still
um did the World Cup in Argentina but he
wanted to get sponsors and everything
around it so they got Coca-Cola and they
got um Adidas that's how everything
started booming that's how everything
that's how all the money started to go
into FIFA do you know what I mean and
there was a time where
um I think it was it could have been
cocoa it could be I can't remember who
it was but they had paid uh joao the
FIFA president at the time
um I think it was like a million pounds
or dollars or whatever it was but it
wasn't for anything it was a bribe oh
okay I think there could have been some
the Argentinian president I can't
remember I can't remember
but Seb clocked it and he kept us done
and it was like I'm gonna use this I'm
gonna use this as ammo because he was I
think it was like the general
secretary's like I understudy he's one
position down from the president
um and he was like I'm going to use this
because I can't be the general secretary
for the rest of my life I want to be the
FIFA president I want to be the FIFA
president so on a back door thing I was
like I'm gonna give you one more time
then I want you to gracefully bow out
because I've got this on you because I
want to be president
so let me hold
he announced in the next election type
of thing
um or the next
um when he they announced the World Cup
in 19 I can't remember 1992 I can't
remember what it was he said oh I'm
gonna bow out and then uh no it was 1998
actually because that's what said became
president
um so yeah he had that but the interview
backstage was like I can't believe it
this is step to the interview I can't
believe it he's been in the hair for so
long I'm gonna miss him you know he's my
mentor and he just snaked him bloody he
[ __ ] snaked him yeah yeah but
um so the whole thing is about how seb's
illustrious career went from oh the face
of FIFA to borderline corruption just
corruption so how it works is obviously
Europe is classed as UEFA in terms of
the football yeah and there's like six
others there's obviously uh North
America South America uh Asia and Africa
um but they're called different things
like Africa is called CAF Asia's called
ACN or something like that and there's
konkan some things all these different
ones but all every country has one vote
to say where they want the World Cup to
be
Bots
or the government so let's say let's use
UEFA as an example
there's going only going to be one or
two representatives from
UEFA at the FIFA exhibition
to vote to vote yeah so if for example
I'm the FIFA I'm the UEFA president at
the moment
um or I'm the elect elected nominee to
and put the vote through I can rally all
these men up in Europe and say oh we're
going to vote for let's say for example
Germany's all the terms of the World Cup
an audio man pick Germany pick Germany
pick German pick German and I'll say
okay cool this is Germany
but it's one of those ones where
um
in
in like the islands Caribbean and stuff
they've got more countries than the rest
of actual North America
I think 40 countries because the islands
yeah you have an individual vote and
it's run it's run by one brother
and they all rally around him I can't
remember his name they all rally around
him and he bribes
everyone
he wants all the regardless of
regardless of whatever
um he said to one person if another
another man has come with a better deal
he's snaking you he's snaking you to get
them to get their pee and this is how
the World Cup
situation was all Rocky so it kicked off
properly in the news when
um
Russia got the world cup instead of
England well not not necessarily instead
of England but England were the Front
Runners of the 2018 World Cup but Russia
got it and America were the Front
Runners of the 2022 World Cup this year
but Qatar got it and you're thinking
Qatar has no stadiums qatar's
infrastructure is enough is nowhere near
what America is they um they don't even
identify with football it's going to be
[ __ ] like do you know all these
certain things so you're like yeah yeah
yeah why Qatar so what's going on so but
that is that is literally like that it's
four episodes but it Dives so deep into
how many people snake each other how
many people will do anything to stay in
this in these in this Four Walls of FIFA
and uh the corruption is insane the
corruption is
it on Netflix Oh sick okay
documentary all right cool say less I
think everyone needs to watch it okay
all right okay okay okay okay okay I'll
check it out but last thing I want to
say Obviously World Cup starting soon
guys
um let's let me know let us know in the
comments who you're reading for if your
country's in it Nigeria is not in it and
I'm absolutely yeah of course um going
to talk to us in like a in like a
qualification game I think I didn't talk
I said I think it was either nil no or
one one and we had to win to qualify
um so yeah let us know who you're who
you're supporting and if you think and
let us know who you're gonna who you
think is going to win we're going to
talk about it's going to be a weekly
basis thing oh yeah all right bet
um so just before we finish today yeah I
have got a thread okay
so this one has been going around you've
probably definitely seen it so this is
just a quick one it says I want to hear
the stories of how you found out you
were getting cheated on
okay I think I've seen I've seen signs
similar I think Fair times okay but this
one had me on the road bear people sent
it to me okay and it had me on the ropes
okay so I want to hear the stories of
how you found out you were getting
cheated on okay right
bro this one sweeted me so initial tweet
girl
I found out in my dream oh here we go
fam I found out in my dream yeah yeah
and I woke up the next day and described
the girl to him and even told him the
girl's name and he lied about it and
then I found out his ass is on FaceTime
with the girl I described from my dream
what do you mean he lied about bro okay
reply
fam the reply the Powerball just hit 2
billion and you're wasting That's So
Raven moments on [ __ ]
that's so that's all right
jokes hilarious
um caveat I'm pretty sure I saw someone
win that Powerball
the two billions oh I think 2.04 I think
yeah yeah
ridiculous wow ridiculous yeah yeah
highest win ever yeah yeah yeah That's
So Raven moments bro
having dreams about getting cheated on
you could be making us money
you're gonna be making us money
oh this one's just long yeah she she had
the baby it was light-skinned with blue
eyes and blonde hair
obviously is a black breath it's just
torment oh I couldn't live with that I
could not live with that and the thing
is with me I'm so like that she would
just lie to me forever what's the What's
the title of the thread again how did
you find out you got cheated on WOW
blonde hair
I will look at it I'll look at her and
I'll look at all the nurses in the room
oh fam good for England hospital because
we're testing blood today oh oh right
first perfect Titans out we're testing
DNA today perfect get whoever in here
needs to come in here immediately yeah I
don't say oh no get me yeah 100 get me
saw her text in a bread in the
reflection of her glasses and when I
said what are you doing she said nothing
and locked her screen
I went through her phone when she fell
asleep and found a text that said
thought you said you had a gag reflex
ah bro with that I thought you said you
had a gag you took him yesterday
no not only has he clocked his wife has
been sucking another man's dick
but he's physically read it and he's so
sore with his own eyes lipstore after
that
thought you said you had a gag reflex
and she was in the car texting him
smiling
smart I thought wow
that's not a message
that's not a message I could read Robert
see your message of her telling the next
man I love you oh one million oh I love
your heart I can't read that message
brother I thought do you know the
maddest thing imagine you then start
thinking back but I've deepthroated my
goal bag of times and she she firms it
fam you start thinking what's going on I
can't
like she would be woken up by the sound
of my ribs cracking in my chest
I can never read that message I couldn't
that's the worst thing I've ever heard
that's the worst thing I've ever heard
same same same same same same same same
same same
um oh bro wow next one someone tagged us
on IG on a meme that said two of my
followers have the same boyfriend
as she tagged the two things
wow
followers have the same boyfriend as she
added them no no that's a fight that's
an on-called fight who are you the
referee why are you doing this why are
you doing this the referee why are you
doing this
I was chilling
minding my business and I see that
notification I was minding my business
friends have the same thing
bro this one this one sweeted me my ex
ghosted the girl he was cheating on we
met sorry my ex ghosted the girl he was
cheating on me with and she reported him
missing
wow fam reported him missing
she saw her own man just on milk cartons
well he's in the yard
I wouldn't know where to begin
bro are you missing I would is this you
are you missing I wouldn't know who's
pointing this out there I wouldn't know
where to begin yeah where did I think
you've gone who is it frying I'm flying
up our lunch yeah no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no and my sighting has done that
wow bro wow that's treacherous
I went out of town for a school function
for a week came back and my best friend
at the time sat me down immediately and
said he felt so bad that he smashed and
nutted in her face
and he didn't want me to kiss her
because he'd feel even worse
oh bro what's going on bro what's going
on
bro what's going on that's that man said
bro I'm not gonna lie to you bang your
girl no no not it on her face and I
can't sit here and watch your lips are
up I just I just physically come on
we're boys remember we're boys I
physically can't just sit here and watch
that I think I will do 25 to life oh I
would be doing 25 to life because
I'm stabbing more than one person bro
disgusting right last one he wanted to
deactivate his Instagram account but to
do that you had to sign in on the
website so he gave me his login to do it
on my laptop
when I logged in the first post on his
timeline was from his spam photos of him
in bed with another [ __ ]
bro
plot twist
that would end her that would end her
spam that would end her her man and his
man
her man and his man would end her she
could never tell her friends who she
could never tell her friends why she's
broken up with her mother oh of course
not that would end her he's a cheat I
don't want to talk about it literally
literally he's a cheat I don't want to
talk about it I'm trying to move it he
literally wasn't even my man anyway so I
don't even know why you're grilling me
stop stop it he didn't have a key relax
ladies he was just a tick yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I'm done with it we're moving on let's
get bottomless brunch mostly mimosas
where are we at
yeah I couldn't honestly promise you
couldn't
well read that third one again that that
one
that one which one was that the one the
one uh a common way was because it it
the one I sat for
so we're either talking
um I think it was the third one
I thought you had a gag reflex
I thought you had a gag reflex that one
so you told me that one that when you're
getting wooded in your tonsils you're
gonna be uh uh can't handle it but
I was a fool I was fully in there and I
think you didn't inflate your little
soldier you didn't flinch
thought you had a gag reflex
promise you that's enough yeah that
broke me yeah that's the worst thing I
could possibly read that one and um yeah
yeah yeah I'll be scrambling up the
closest building
I will be scrambling up the closest
building it ready as a job yeah yeah
ready to jump anyway guys thank you for
today if you're still here yeah thank
you very much jump over on patreon.com
and catch us on Thursday and without
further Ado love love
[Music]
foreign